first of all are you safe and healthy
right now in isolation relatively
healthy I'm very safe went for a run on
the Greenbelt this morning and rolled my
ankle but besides that I'm particularly
healthy oh did you put ice on it not yet
it's on my to-do list for today but
things are just piling up so I'll get to
it eventually there's so much to talk
about the show I mean there were so many
emotions in the last episode now that
you've kind of gone through those
emotions sat with it kind of went
through it all in your head what was the
experience like for you to be on the
show oh man it was far more intense than
I initially expected I knew that you
know it was going to be a high-stress
situation with lots of I have emotions
running high for everybody but it was
anything more than I could have
predicted especially with the rest of
the cast being such genuine and
down-to-earth people that I really
really connected with and formed a lot
of friendships live there talking about
connection I'm assuming after watching
this show you've felt a little bit
disappointed a little bit hurt with
everything that was handled by Julia for
you and Brandon but I want to know when
you were on the show what was the
emotions for you with her so it was
obviously I you know I lived it seeing
everything now I'm seeing some new
information but as I was going through
it I mean I was aware that we were in a
unique situations if we you're not
dating somebody and living with them
while they're also dating somebody else
that you're living with yeah well I
could appreciate the nuances of the
situation in that it's not easy for
anybody myself included I know that
Julia was really conflicted and that
throughout the entire process yeah like
she kind of kept going back and forth
and it was frustrating and it was not
the easiest but also I empathize with
her I understood it's it's not easy to
just like try and feelings on him off
for somebody or just to make a snap
decision if you're not used to that and
so as frustrating as it was I did want
her to have that space and time to
figure out what
I didn't want her to feel like her
choices taken away or that again I
didn't want to be a default choice as
well right did you feel that way I
didn't until we watched everything as it
aired but before you watch the actual
show while you were there did you ever
feel that in your senses that you were
the side option I like I said I I didn't
feel like I was a side option because
again as everything Julie had told to me
I felt like she was being transparent
when she said hey I'm still confused
about this thing with Josh or I'm
confused about this thing with Brandon
to me she had never indicated that she
was leaning one way or another like for
instance in Episode two before the rose
ceremony where she talks about wanting
Brandon's Rose that hadn't really been
conveyed to me it was had very much been
a case I'm still confused so at the time
I didn't feel like I was just being put
on the back burner on the side to me she
was conflicted and I was trying to give
her space to figure things out
did you talk to her after Monday I heard
the episode did you have a chance to
discuss what you saw on the show and
compete I guess have peace with it she
she reached out after the show and I
told her that I wanted some I was gonna
take some space and time this time to
kind of process everything and also I
wanted to see kind of what else came to
light over the next couple weeks after
the show was airing because I didn't
want to kind of you know try to make
peace with something and then another
issue kind of pop up so I've just been
kind of taking like I said a space trust
trying to process and work through
everything and I've told her that I'll
reach out if and when I feel like we can
have a good conversation about it it's
funny you say finding your peace it's
almost like every time the show comes on
and you must have some type of anxiety
for the next what's gonna happen next do
you feel that way for sure
has Brandon connected with you did he
has he apologized in any way yeah after
the show Brandon did apologize to me and
so we were kind of came to an agreement
so I you know a lot of people been
saying a lot of her things about Brandon
I think again people have to take into
account the circumstances in the
situation that we're are as you know it
is a dating show about dating multiple
people off and everybody's gonna have a
different approach to that I think like
I said Britton apologized I wouldn't say
we're close by any means but we're on
fine terms I think that's important
Miller I like to let him apologize and
actually take it so that's good that you
were able to do that one of the great
things about you also is the fact that
you responded to the backlash of Julia
God I mean bullying is not allowed I had
social media there was so many comments
made while I was important for you to
step up and actually your put your voice
out there you know protecting her almost
because it's easy for people watching
this to again think of us almost as
persona is when were actual people
yeah it's reality TV but that was our
reality that we lived julia is a person
and we all make mistakes
I think hers just happened to be aired
on national television which obviously
is gonna result in a lot more backlash
I really appreciated all the support
everybody was showing me but I didn't
want it to again come at the cost of
somebody else being put down that's
that's not something that I support um
if you want to support me if you want to
support my music I love it I appreciate
it
but I I think we what we put out into
the universe I think we get that back
and I think if somebody is just putting
on negativity and putting somebody down
I don't think that's helpful for anybody
yeah I agree synergy it's true and you
have a way of listening to that synergy
because you are putting music out there
coming back was a song the reflection of
what you went through and you you know a
way to move forward with it what does
that song mean to you to be able to
express it that way as an artist and let
people hear your emotions so that song
was a really really unique song for me
it was actually the first song that I
wrote on piano nice and on top of that I
mean pianos not typically my instrument
but beyond
that it was looking back at how
everything was shown and being able to
watch that the audience being able to
and everybody be able to see kind of the
entire creative process for me was
really really interesting from you know
me first meeting Julia and kind of
watching the roller coaster that we went
on to the inspiration for this song
being like you know them living on the
stage to finally like the creation and
the culmination of this creative process
but that was just also me just doing my
thing regardless of anything else that
was going on that's what I would be
doing it if this had been an interaction
with a girl back here in Austin and I
had just been sitting at home it just
happened to be that there are cameras
around and people were able to kind of
witness it but for me a lot of times
most often music is a form of catharsis
for me it's how I work through things
that's how I process things it's maybe
writing songs about the stuff regardless
of whether I was publishing it or not
mm-hmm are you hesitant to listening to
your heart I often can struggle with you
know logic versus emotions and kind of
head versus heart that kind of constant
battle and for me a lot of times in the
past I very much have had more of a
logical approach to things and be like
oh well it's not the right time in my
life or so-and-so and whatever and
actually for the first time is last year
year and a half or so I have felt like I
was finally in a place to be in a
relationship where do you that I felt
like I had so much work I wanted to do
on myself and so many areas I need to
improve on I wanted to take care of that
and kind of become a better version of
myself before I brought somebody else
into that and going into the show it was
kind of this I went in with a very open
mind because I was in this place that I
was gonna be as open as I possibly could
I felt good about everything in my life
and so I was just kind of kind of just
yeah I was gonna follow my heart and see
where that took me how was it for you
was a roller coaster
[Laughter]
what what do you look for in a partner
hmm I definitely look for someone you
know who's grounded in themselves
similarly the same way that I I had a
lot of work that I want to do in myself
and I still do like we're always trying
to grow we're always trying to learn
that's something I really really value
when a partner is self reflection and
trying to work on yourself acknowledging
that you're not perfect but admitting
that you're trying to work on that
that's something that's huge for me
also obviously I think having a bit of
drive and ambition on their own just
because I'm I can be a very ambitious
very driven person and I think I need a
little bit of that intensity in the
partner but at the same time somebody
who can also kind of get me to calm down
a little bit and take five minutes off
would you consider being the next
Bachelor
I would consider it it seems like a lot
of people are trying to push for that
I mean if it's an option I'll definitely
have to talk about it at that point but
that's a bridge we haven't even gotten
through listen to your heart yet I can't
I would consider you would concern you'd
want to go through all of that again
well okay different circumstances okay I
would be so much better prepared for it
at least I think mentally because it was
that's the first time I've ever had
you know cameras everywhere all the time
I think going into it now I'd be a
little bit like alright I'm a little bit
more used to this although The Bachelor
versus listen to your heart
dating thirty women at once that sounds
like a [ __ ] like a chaplain